alright let's talk about Burger King
they have come out with slightly lower
calorie French fries and they even gave
them a witty name saddest fries that's
right they're regular french fries are
340 calories of serving and these french
fries although they're fried in the same
frying oil they're only going to be 270
calories as you can see that's slightly
different than their regular french fry
because they are crinkled which is very
exciting and obviously causes more mouth
movement which then will burn calories
as here I know I made that part up so
just a little more info about the fry
itself they are actually going to be
fried in the exact same fryer that the
regular burger king fries are frightened
but this has to do with the batter they
are somehow making the batter less
caloric but you're still eating fried
stuff I guess this is good because you
know it helps you sort of make decent
choices when you go to these places but
these places aren't really about making
good choices right the first one is
anything that's diet it's like people
think oh diet cookies I can have the box
you know versus like - just regular
cookies or whatever you know it's like
oh I would have ordinarily had a small
fryer now I'll have two large because
it's diet so why not and they end up you
know consuming more calories and they
would have to begin with the other thing
is mock my woods this is gonna be the
sketches shape-ups burger game because
people think oh great all I have to do
is just get the saddest fries and now we
losing weight no time I'm on my way to
bikini body in a second no you need to
calm down on the french fries oh wait
those Skechers shape-ups inside were
they were called today
did anyone wear those do people really
my ankle return and I didn't lose weight
night and well obviously you didn't like
sitting on your couch with the shoes on
and expect something to happen you know
so I feel like it's kind of in that
category of like oh you don't just lose
weight when you put the shoe on yeah
exactly like you know it's it's it's
look it's great that they're going in
this direction I think it's fantastic
that fast food chains in the last five
to ten years have made a huge huge
effort to you know add fruit or add
salads or at you know
great cool PC done now that being said
it's just like and by the way on a side
note kudos to the guy that came up with
satisfies that man like he obviously is
in a big chair right now yeah um but
yeah I really think it's just it's only
20% difference I think that people
unfortunately will will be like you know
what I'm gonna get the satisfies and
then two burgers yeah yeah we go for
that 20% but the bigger issue here is
people aren't reading between the lines
because when I was looking at this you
know it said that a rep for Burger King
when asked what it was that made it less
it actually is something that prevented
that they want disclose that prevents
the oil from soaking in more right in
the batter I'm like what are they doing
it in kitty litter they put it in there
it's like an oil retardant like you know
I just don't understand and it's like
what is that gonna do you know to your
body it's like how spunda it causes a DD
and this causes cancer sweet'n low or
whatever it's like what is that going to
do usually honestly you know the full
fat the full whatever is actually more
beneficial to your body your life and
that actually goes that goes to where
you were saying about how people then
compensate by eating more because even
if you think about diet soda you're
getting no calories but you're putting
all this aspartame in your body and then
on top of that you probably drink two or
three sodas when you may have only drank
one regular coke filled with all that
and the general portions loves Burger
King are bigger than McDonald's so a
small fry and McDonald's that's full fat
actually has less calories that's not
true it is true and I don't work for
McDonald's so you're saying a small fry
at McDonald's and a small fry at Burger
King or not that is fry small yeah that
still has more calories than a small
McDonald's full fat fry because movie
got them to take away supersize